look i got a hard optimism bias i don't
believe this could happen i have an
optimism bias on this one it's just nah
man life is stable america's great
everything's fine it's a silly protest
nothing's going to happen
oh that's refreshing that's that's nice
to hear from
that's an optimism bias yeah but you've
got to you call me an optimism
by assault that that's me all the time
right i mean i don't mind that you have
to be various
optimism bias it is it is a it is a
fallacy
it will get you killed so i have been
in so many situations in conflict where
you're like nah there's no way that
could happen and then boom
it happens molotov goes flying explosion
happens and you're like
don't assume what you expect you got to
think about what's possible
and you know and where you are and too
often
you know we look at what's going on in
jazz you've got something very different
from occupy wall street
occupy wall street didn't ever even i
think
what's the word i don't think anyone
anyone from occupy ever actually broke
anything
except the sink in the in the burger
king because
across the street from occupy was a
burger king and they'd go to the
bathroom there and somebody was like
leaning on it and it broke
they were like taking a shower in the
bathroom oh nice you didn't have people
smashing windows and stuff
right you did have like one dude take a
dump on a cop car or something like that
but over the past 10 years things have
really escalated in terms of how these
protests go out and now it's been fires
and destruction and
burning vehicles now you've got
seemingly normal people in new york
throwing molotovs like these two lawyers
throwing molotovs life in prison they're
facing life
you consider all of these all of the
psychosis that's been building up for a
long time these people are nuts men
i heard somebody was preaching and they
said that there it was a black lives
matter activist saying they were tired
of their people being genocided
and i'm like bro isn't it the single
digits like the amount of unarmed
black men who have been killed in this
past year or whatever nine in 2019
in 2019 and that's bad and i believe we
need place reform we should deal with
that
but come on bro he was saying it was
genocide and they believe this stuff
they are going insane
we are in we violent crime is down
across the board
better than it's ever been lethal crime
is way down life-saving uh phone calls
are are up because of cell phones
meaning people are more likely to get
treated
yeah poverty is re reduced to nothing
because of
of capitalism yeah and i think we're
facing the uh
the results of our success a lack of
purpose
com so then you end up with a desperate
need to fill that purpose so people
create a purpose and say that you know
people in this country are being
genocided or something nonsensical
and you get zealots fanatics who
literally will tear down
thomas jefferson who will deface abraham
lincoln
who will demand winston churchill this
is the uk now
and they show up to seattle thinking
they're in the revolution and they bring
guns and they give them the young people
who clearly don't
don't know what they're doing so listen
i'll put it this way i have an optimism
bias i really
can't imagine a scenario where we get
that call where someone texts you and
says are you okay are you okay what
happened and you're like whoa what
happened and then they're like
oh i just heard about this that this
happening you know near you
when i was in uh new york when that
black identity extremist killed those
two cops
yeah right by our house literally like
within a block
yep the first text i got was are you
okay outside of the deli i went to
probably every day probably only a few
hours before you went and got
a sandwich or something seriously every
single day i would go to this deli and
yup
right i would i would walk right past
that spot every week
we would have magic the gathering night
yep
and i would go to the deli and load it
up with ho ho's and twinkies and kit
kats and other nonsense and bring in big
bags of nasty snacks
yeah from the deli and then right in
front of that deli two cops got executed
yep i get a text saying are you okay and
i'm like what happened and then also in
a helicopter
like 20 feet over my building swoops
over and i'm like what the
yeah i couldn't believe it happened in
front of my building they were minority
like down the street from me
so that's what i'm that's what i'm
worried about it's like everything's
been so calm and stable for us here in
the u.s
i think most americans have an optimism
bias bro i remember
you know three years ago i was in a
group chat with a bunch of political
reporters and stuff
and i was talking about my fears for a
civil war
and there were a couple people just
saying like that'll never happen you're
wrong it's impossible and saying all
these things
and i tried to explain to them like how
i think it could happen and what would
happen
and a lot of people who follow me know
that this is what i described
antifa getting more aggressive and it's
not hard to predict because it was
literally happening it's like i'm saying
like i'm looking into the future and the
lottery numbers are these
i was literally like wow man if antifa
is going to do this and the right's
going to do this what do you think is
going to happen next year if it gets
worse
and they would tell me it won't get
worse it's over the security state is
too powerful
so that's this is my fear you wake up at
three in the morning
and you're like your phone's going crazy
and it's like your mom being like turn
on the news turn on the news
and it's like gun battle seattle streets
maybe not
that's like i'm saying optimism bias but
what's what's going on in france right
now
well i mean it's it's gang wars i don't
know if it i don't know what
see it's the the pandemic i feel is is
the root to a lot of this people were
locked in 40 million people people don't
know how to do that
comfortably you know we're we're social
species we're used to
going out and living our lives normally
when you when you take like the base
fundamentals of life when people already
didn't have a purpose
you take it take away what whatever
thing they did have and people are going
to go crazy i don't care who you are
you're you're
you lock someone in their their spot for
whoever knows how long you're gonna
you're gonna get cuckoo
three months no job no boredom right and
then you inundate them with this video
footage of all this crazy stuff
right their mind snaps and it's not just
here it's like everywhere people
lock down the whole planet was locked
down because of covid
this is why i think they didn't like
jordan peterson you know what one of
things jordan peterson would tell
all these people who listen to him find
the heaviest thing you can carry
and carry it yeah yeah he was telling
people to make their purpose to find
their responsibility do it yourself
yeah do it yourself and that's actually
something that's interesting like i
mentioned on friday it's like
i see a lot of issues with politics so
i'm actually contemplating getting into
politics
if you if everyone all feels that
there's something wrong with politics
get into politics yeah and that's not
what they're doing they're just going
they're wrong they're they're bad and
it's like well why aren't you going and
fixing it getting
into politics and and trying to make a
difference or
or get you know becoming a cop becoming
a police officer to be that police
officer
in your neighborhood this is the the
where are these people that are actually
going out and doing these things instead
of
complaining you're talking about the
underlying ethos of
feminist academia so there's there's a
there's a meme comic where it's like
uh uh a woman reads a pamela where it
says like there's no women in stem and
she's shocked
yeah and then she goes to college and
then the next panel's like she comes out
with a gender studies degree holding a
sign saying more women in stem
it's like go go join a stem field right
but here's the point i want to make
about jordan peterson
when he comes out and tells people hey
man like find your purpose
clean your room yeah that's bad for the
revolutionaries
the revolutionaries need idle hands
disenfranchised people yeah right
exactly
they need the right and the left to be
disenfranchised right because an angry
right is the enemy to rally everyone
against
and disenfranchise leftists can join
your ranks but if you get a self-help
guru who's like
clean your room and then they start
doing it you're like no stop stop being
responsible stop fixing your life no be
angry
be angry at the bad man it's like no
you're the bad man
trying to convince me to be angry at
everyone it's like no
i want it we want to be like together
that's that's what i keep seeing it
their their worst fear
is us holding each other's hands you
know lifting each other
up it's like that's what we need to
focus on we need more people like that
bringing us up bringing everyone
together and lifting everyone up
they want to manage the conflict so they
can use it to gain power for themselves
yeah
you know you've talked about what's
serena williams husband's name
alexis ohanian okay so he he left his
job
and he dedicated board members 60
million dollars
yeah to to whatever and you know i
thought about that after that episode i
was like you know what
well so let's get some comments real
quick
reddit which is now one of the most
prominent social media sites
he recently announced he was stepping
down from the board he wants them to
replace him with a black man
or a black person i think and that he
was going to be dedicating
all of the earnings off of his holdings
to
programs to help you know the black
community right so
i'm not necessarily i'm not talking
about the first part of that the second
part
he is well off he doesn't need that
all those ex all the extra money income
from that
so for him to give it to some you know
a community that needs it that is
amazing
and i didn't i didn't do this before but
i'm clapping for you
because that's amazing that's what we
need i i'm not a millionaire it's a
private chair i'm not a billionaire
if i was a billionaire i wouldn't need a
billion dollars
i would be pumping it into everywhere i
can
but here listen and that's what that's
that when i see people like that and
he's like you know what
i made a lot of money i could take these
millions of dollars and and pump it into
a community that needs it it's like yes
we need that and i i didn't you know i
always felt bad since uh that episode
listen it's been on my mind
i don't know what is that that's what we
need though but what what is what is
alexis says a
liquid reality in terms of his assets
how much our
stock how much can actually be spent i'm
sure he's got more than enough to live
but there's there's there's no there's
no i'm as far as i can tell i mean maybe
aside from vladimir putin no one's got
liquid
um dollars in the amount of a billion
right right yeah sure it's stock or
stuff it's tied up they can move it
around their right start though
that's that's what we need we need to
start moving forward
so i i i can respect the fact that he's
saying like i've i've got enough i'm
good i'm going to give to other people
yeah and jack dorsey announced he was
going to give
a billion dollars right and uh i i do
think the issue here
is the identitarianism in both of those
moves
they're saying like jack dorsey's i
think he said women program women's
programs girls program and alexis
ohanian said
um black programs and i'm like
if it's private charity in that regard
do whatever you want yeah but i just
want to be careful because
the next step above that is involuntary
right so so there's a new york times
story that talks about how republicans
give more in charity
okay but democrats give more involuntary
charity
right that's that's literally so it's
funny they were like while republicans
do give more to charitable causes
democrats actually spend more per capita
in charitable issues through involuntary
means
involuntary and i'm like you mean to
tell me that they're being taxed and
they don't want to do this so they're
doing it because they have to do it
right so my concern is as long as we
don't cross that line
of government mandated racial pretext
for redistribution of wealth
which is i'm not even touching into the
racial part of it because i feel like
we've talked about this you know we have
to fix what
you know the the lower class areas that
need
the most help and yes
it does it links it it merges with a
racial issue
because there happens to be a lot of
minorities in these areas
for historically they're they're not
getting the same amount of schooling
we got to fix that you know well i think
school is trash
you're right i think anybody should go
to education is a whole another
conversation
right that we can talk about because i
agree with you completely the education
systems also
look it's this simple bro we have we
have these people arguing that systemic
racism
quite literally means that black people
have less generational wealth which i've
talked about yeah
and because of that we need to help
black people and i'm like
you are correct and the way you do that
is through class-based
issues yeah so you will by your own
argument disproportionately help the
minority communities because you claim
they're disproportionately
poor or in poverty well i mean you also
make some some
rich neighborhood doesn't need help does
it do well
right they don't but here's the issue
when you come out and say
that you know the asian community okay
is underprivileged they're not but i'm
just using an example because it's like
i'm part asian
the asian community is underprivileged
therefore we must give money to asians
would i get money i don't need it that's
ridiculous just because of my race no no
no no what you need to do is you need to
give it to people who actually need some
kind of help
now i'm not a fan of giving i'm a fan of
teaching
so you know you give a man a fish teach
men to fish that whole saying
so i think what we need to do is
class-based solutions and it solves
everyone's problems but guess what
guess what the revolutionary marxist
communist people
they don't want that yeah they're
standing there standing in the middle of
chaz saying
some some what looked like a white white
guy
saying look you need to go find a black
person and give them
ten dollars yeah and i was just thinking
to myself like how degrading is that
like walking up to you know
you need this more than i do look here i
am you need this
i i don't you you clearly need this it's
like is that not
degrading well hold on i would be
like pretty pissed off if anyone came to
me
and did that sure sure in my worldly
travels i was warned
in some countries you do not tip okay it
is an
insult really yeah so i was told uh that
in some
asian cultures like japan or china or
south korea
tipping is an insult really it's how you
insult them by saying
clearly you can't afford to pay your
staff your service is poor and your
business is bad
so you need this more than i do they
don't they they think
if i give you a number now in recent
times i've been told
that they re they realize the stupidity
of you know
the pride just take the money yeah but
that's
a funny point if somebody walked up to
me and said
i realized that you're not completely
white so i want to give you ten dollars
you know my response would be
thanks bro it just takes ten dollars
yeah
sure looks ten bucks man so if if you
know yeah
but that attitude it's not it's not
solving anything it's not
it's i know you're not going yeah i you
know what i hate white people less now
yeah thank you thank you all right no
that's not that's not working like that
it's not doing anything
yeah i think solving any any systemic
issues that they're
marching for there was a uh a an article
that was going around
from like critical race theory people
the woke left specifically saying that
they need to start eavesdropping on
conversations from mixed-race people
okay you know why no tell me no they're
not going to tell you this
okay you're making us oh because when
you go to a white person whose only
experience is their white family
you can easily convince them that they
can't understand your plight you don't
understand what we've been through oh
okay then you go to a minority family
and say you don't understand the
privilege they have
and so there was this viral threat from
a woman claiming that she was going to
buy a house
and she was told by the loan officer
it's common for people to get gifts of
fifty to a hundred thousand dollars oh
yeah i saw that and she's like this is
what white privilege is
the problem with mixed race families is
that they have white family members
presumably mixed race meaning white to
be honest i see okay which is often what
they mean
so for me growing up having a dad who's
white i'm like
why are you wrecking on my dead like
that that offends me
oh but i'm also you know technically a
minority right the smallest minority in
the country
so all of a sudden what i was saying to
them it got really bad
when they would say things about white
people and be like what about my family
that my family was negatively impacted
by the policies you enacted
even though we were like the most
marginalized community
in the country just because of the race
of my father but this is so stupid
because
white people are poor too right there's
more poor way
it's like you you think all white people
can just afford to give a hundred grand
to the the first time like house owner
like do you
think that that's not the case it's
ridiculous listen they think that
yeah and i know that's the problem but
that's why i was saying that like the
idea of a
white mixed family breaks that apart
yeah exactly they keep pushing this
racist narrative that's like
trying to divide us and it's like it's
ridiculous
i can't stand it they in my opinion
a lot of this comes from revolutionary
lunatics
who need a catalyst for the destruction
of the country yeah
i've talked to them it's not a grand
conspiracy these are fringe weirdos who
work in these these
these activist groups that do these kind
of weird things and they straight up
said
you know from the ashes of the old we
will build the new so they're like let
it let it all burn
let it fall apart and i kid you not i
know some of these people who voted for
trump
because they were thinking like wow
trump will really destroy everything
then you had like three years of
prosperity and like the expansion of
like
american nationalism and stuff yeah now
they're maybe going like oops
you i just watched v for vendetta and
right now what's happening
it feels like that scene where the ch
the high
chancellor's getting all pissed off and
he's like yeah yeah man
we we need to you know spread start
reminding the the citizens of why they
need us like
yeah tell and then it's just like the
news is just constantly like oh man
hurricanes terrorist attacks covid19
racial issues and it's like this is the
democrats the democrats were the
original
like racists in this country they
nothing's changed
you know it's it's interesting because
you see many black people out there
going
what is going on like i love trump i'm
i'm we we've had the lowest um
unemployment rate right forever this is
like
all of us have jobs now what are you
what do you guys what are you talking
about we're making moves
this is this is what we wanted you know
i can say one thing who is that guy who
said at least trump hasn't started any
new wars oh mills
i said it was i think that's what it was
that was mel's who said that gates
sorry yeah gates he said at least trump
hasn't started anything at least
seriously that's like the greatest thing
he could do well
i mean regardless of what he meant by it
i'm like that's actually a good point
yeah like what it was funny somebody
posted on facebook and they were like i
really miss obama or something
yeah and i'm like oh this is my time to
shine
oh you love it when people say that
don't you type in fingers and i'm like
i'm going you appeared on my timeline
honestly i i
i didn't know half of the stuff about
obama that that i should write
you told me about and i'm just like is
that real you know you know you know
that any
you know the animal song where he sings
all the countries
yes no you know do you know count
dankilla did one too where he names all
the countries
and it's like the dentist i haven't seen
that one actually so it would be funny
to write a song of all the
horrible things obama did yeah like i
don't know extrajudicial assassinations
the indefinite detention provision in
the ndaa
the expansion of the authorization
freeze of military force in the middle
east the expansion of our troops
in uh afghanistan the use of the
espionage act against more
whistleblowers than any other president
in history combined
they called him they called him the
deporter in chief black lives matter
started under barack obama under barack
obama race relation
the perception of race relations
decrease come on man
the dude was responsible for the
expansion of the drone strike program
which like literally blew up children
and civilians
and you know what he did when they would
kill civilians they decided one
one day to be like well how old were the
civilians
wow well they were between the ages of
18 and 30.
military aid yeah fighting age fighting
age
we'll just call them fighting age uh
slap that label on yeah so that's how
they tried to get around
killing civilians yeah that's incredible
favorite story yeah benghazi man i mean
come on
yeah right fast and furious dude that
was dude when they were giving guns to
cartels yeah
man you want to talk about obama nah i'm
sorry so trump's got all his problems
man but not starting a new war that's
actually kind of a big deal that's a
huge deal so you know what man i
i i say fool me once shame on shame on
you that's why i voted for obama the
first time i was like yeah it's
something different you know everybody
told me all this good stuff about i
remember being in chicago and people
cheering and i'm like wow
he's like an outsider he wasn't even in
politics he was like a local community
dude
yeah and then he gets in and it's like
the one ring as soon as he got it it was
like cast it into the fire and obama was
like
no just like that
i kind of wanted a little bit more but
that was pretty good
nope he walked out of it and he put it
up man that was it man
so you know it it really is a tough
period in terms of the upcoming election
it's crazy it feels like there's a
constant attack on my brain
i read news all day every day and i
don't just read one source
i read forums from the left forums from
the right
i read mainstream corporate democrat
articles i read
hardcore trump conspiracy sites i read
everything i want to know what people
are thinking why they're thinking it and
i really
cannot reconcile everything i'm seeing
on the streets
with burning buildings with the data
proving
riots make republicans win with them
coming out with data claiming
biden is going to win with the betting
odds that's ridiculous
maybe i don't see it if they cheat you
know
look man well if he's got the betting
odds like i'll do that bet against him
make more money that way dude i know
people who made a lot of money in 2016.
yeah i'm sure because it was like 10 to
1. oh wow some people were like i
figured it was 10 bucks i 100 bucks i
was like wow
i didn't care about the 10 bucks yeah
but the the the the bookies were
convinced like you're gonna lose your
money yeah and then
having to pay out for it i know some
people who made a couple grand wow
because i know some people who are legit
convinced they're like i know he's gonna
win you're wrong he's to win he's going
to win
yeah so maybe that's it maybe go go put
your predict
bets on trump to win but i'll tell you
what man if you
think you've if the trump supporters you
think you've got this one in the bag no
i don't buy it
no in patterson new jersey right now
there's a huge controversy
because 20 of the mail in
vote was disqualified oh yeah and now a
leader of the naacp is calling for the
election to be
completely nullified and there are
people complaining why was my vote
disqualified
they said that around 3 000 or so votes
is a local election
the signatures on them did not match
previous signatures yeah but the
democrats don't want that to happen
they're like we've
we've worked so long and hard to set
this up
the election must go on no no i think
they do i mean so look at look at what
happened with 2016 you think they do
what
they want they want mail in voting no no
i'm saying they don't want the election
cancelled oh i think they want
everything they can get
well if the election is cancelled
they'll blame trump they'll say he's a
dictator and they're going to remove him
by the
via the military well if the election is
cancelled that's how is that
how's that on him though because trump
has to be re-elected and so they'll
argue there must be an election
and that from this point on trump must
step down or some other ridiculous
nonsense
that's my whole point yeah in 2016 they
pulled a crafty move
after they lost they claimed trump
cheated and that you know he's
illegitimate and we went through
you know two and a half three still
believe that they're still saying that
they know it's not true
they know for a fact not true the
transcripts have been released we've
seen the witness statements where they
said there's no evidence
then they would go on tv and lie they
don't believe it though well it's not
they don't believe it that they know
it's not true
it's not a question of belief it's
knowledge they know there is no evidence
they were straight up asked under oath
in closed door proceedings do you have
evidence no
then why did you say you did i saw it on
tv
they would go on tv and claim it was
true and then when they got when they
got uh
questioned i'm not talking about the
democrats in like
politics i'm talking about the people
democrats that are seeing this stuff
yes the voters yeah they hate trump
because they believe
to in their core that he was colluding
with russia
and all this stuff they hate what
they've been told for so long
they hate him because and this is partly
trump's fault they were told to hate him
sort of but trump plays into it too hard
and
they and and the the the people in media
love that trump plays the game
so i've talked to a lot of my friends
and i
always whenever we get into this
political stuff i'm like you know trump
never called nazis very fine people
right
and they go that's not true i saw it i
said did you pull up the article and
they're like
oh wait what right so you actually
pulled the transcript
you can see him say i'm not talking
about the neo-nazis they should be
condemned totally
yeah and then they're like but what was
he saying then i'm like
did you ever actually read the story and
see what was going on yeah
and what trump was trying to say and who
he condemned like no i didn't right
and it took me actually telling you to
go look for it yeah because they're not
looking for it well now see i actually
watch his speeches and listen to him
speak and i'm like oh okay
i get what you're saying and then i read
the the news
like something totally different like
clockwork right clockwork
spinning it in a way that is not what
you said yeah
take a look at them and open it what was
the recent this is hilarious the recent
uh rule change
oh right npr publishes trump
administration finalizes rule stripping
lgbtq rights in healthcare
yep and it's like is that what happened
i was like that's always interesting to
find out
to enlighten us he defined the term sex
not to include gender identity
obama changed i think it was 2016 that
in health care
sex discrimination included identity and
trump set a rule saying no
it means biological sex okay i'm not
saying if they'll like it or agree with
it or hate it whatever that's not the
point the point is
it is a far cry from saying that he's
stripping rights from the lgbtq
community
it's a huge difference when he's
literally just changing a rule back from
a couple of years ago that obama changed
in the first place
right now you now it's it's a semantic
argument
it's like arguing it's it's it's it's
literally what i talk about when i say
hydroxic acid
it's like it's true but it's also
water right so like for those that
aren't familiar with it it's called the
dihydrogen monoxide hoax you could say
something like hydroxic
acid can eat through metal and i'm gonna
splash in your face and then you get
scared and it's like it's water dude
so yes the rule change may impact the
rights of transgender people
that's serious but you have to explain
to people what's really going on with
the rule change
instead they go for the most hyperbolic
and exaggerated take to make it seem
like you know trump is going crazy
and then there's like there's some viral
tweets there was one
from uh you you might know shoe on head
she's a big youtuber
she tweeted in 2016 you know calm down i
don't think like trump is literally
taking away gay rights or anything right
and then after this rule change she
posted a tweet where it was like
you know oops and everyone was like man
that aged like milk and it's like
that's technically man it's to to
actually get people to understand
why the rule was changed in the first
place and why was it changed back you
have to have an intelligent conversation
they don't want to have
the reality is bring back intelligent
conversations
please if if you have in
medical practice someone asserting that
they are a different
biological sex that can affect how
medical treatment is performed on them
that's true
so the argument is not in some instances
about transgender rights right as much
as it is about
proper medical treatment and liability
issues so
if you saw somebody who had their id
like someone's passing on the ground
and it looks you know the individual is
female
and you look at the id female and so you
say okay it's a female i have to apply
certain medical treatment in a certain
capacity then it turns out they're
biologically male
that means there are different medical
procedures there's different different
doses
right different doses everything's
different yeah be careful yeah so they
passed the law
i think it was in 1991 for the first
time
91 i think it was only one i did a whole
thing about it we did this whole story
for uh
subrest now it's called scanner where
when they would do clinical trials
for medication they wouldn't do it on
women
really and then they were shocked to
find for some reason painkillers didn't
work on women
yep so they passed this law saying okay
from now on medical medicines have to be
trialled on men and women separately hmm
that makes sense right recently huh
that that recently in the past not even
30 years
we didn't realize that maybe men and
women have biological differences that
have different
medicine will have different effects
right so but you also have you know
brain
uh blood brain barrier stuff brain
capacity the nether regions for obvious
reasons will be affected differently
yeah like viagra for instance so now
when you have this rule change
saying like changing the definition of
sex to include identity
it could actually impact proper medical
procedure ultimately i think you know
what we saw today with the supreme court
was their ruling that in that if you are
to discriminate on the basis of identity
or sexuality
you inherently discriminate on the basis
of sex and this caused a huge uproar not
because i'm not seeing um the
high-profile conservatives that are
complaining about this
okay are not saying we shouldn't give
rights to these people no they're saying
don't legislate from the bench
right now maybe they're being hypocrites
i don't know i don't follow all their
complaints
but the complaint for the most part is
the democrats have been trying to pass
this legislation for a long long time
and have never gotten it through
for the supreme court to just come out
now and say no it's true you're done
case closed is subverting the
an entire branch of government yeah
that's not cool well look man
i think people shouldn't discriminate
for a lot of reasons uh for in
employment but maybe there is a
consideration that
legislation should be handled by the you
know legislative branch
i guess the concern is they weren't
getting the job done but that's not the
job of the supreme court so
yeah agreed thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode